Doug trembles early work was that a
company called graphic film in Los
Angeles the small studio produced a
documentary about space flight for the
new york world's fair the film and mr.
trembles work in particular cut the eye
of director Stanley Kubrick who
eventually hired him to create effects
for his film 2001 a Space Odyssey he
went on to supervise effects for the
film Andromeda Strain soon after he made
his directorial debut the what has
become a cult classic the environmental
science fiction film silent running
listed on his resume as a visual effects
supervisor are a few other films you
also may have heard of Close Encounters
of the Third Kind Star Trek the motion
picture and Blade Runner each one earned
him an Academy Award nomination in the
visual effects category he returned to
the director's chair with his 1983 film
brainstorm and has continued to work and
create to this very day his recent
visual effects work can be seen in
Terrence Malick's the Tree of Life the
Gordon East Sawyer award is presented by
the Academy to an individual whose
technical contributions have brought
credit not just to himself but to the
industry we have tonight there's no way
to pay proper tribute to his long record
of accomplishment but perhaps this will
come close it's with great pleasure that
I now present the Academy's Gordon Esau
reward it's mr. Douglas Trumbull
wow this is awesome but before I get
started I wanted to congratulate Mila
for greatest performance and the most
difficult role
I like to thank the academy of motion
picture arts and sciences the Science
and Technology Council and this room of
terrific friends it's been a very long
career of collaboration with a lot of
really amazing artists and scientists
and engineers throughout all these years
hundreds and hundreds of them and it's
been a great pleasure to collaborate
with all of you I thank Richard headland
my very very good friend Peter Anderson
John and Kate erlend who just loaned me
a green screen for some experiments I'm
doing thank you very much the crowd over
here at vision research you have been
loading me phantom 65 and gold cameras
for high-speed photography research I
don't know if there's anybody here from
Stewart film screen but screens are a
big part of the equation and they're
helping me build a whole new kind of
movie screen right now which we're going
to assemble at my stage next month and
so thanks to Stewart film screen Larry
paul at christie digital christie
digital has been helping me break some
frontiers in high frame rate projection
we're now projecting movies at 120
frames in 3d which John alluded to I'm
not going to go into great detail about
that tonight but it's one of the things
I'm cooking on to John Loughrey I was
counting on John that's a tough one so I
want to accept this in a you know in the
spirit of a kind of a affirmation of my
work which is ongoing as you know there
is there there there's no there's no
specific Academy category for what I to
I'm kind of all over the place and
as John said and he stole one of my
lines I am trying to figure out a way to
make a movie that you are in rather than
looking at and that's kind of the
direction I'm going in right now we're
in this really amazing time right now
about the technology of motion pictures
and the art of motion pictures it is
about art and technology and those two
forces working together toward a common
goal as many of you know I've been a
huge advocate of 70 millimeter I've been
associated with shows can I help take
imax public a few years ago which is
like the fastest way to eat film on
earth and we've all been through hole
there's careers and God knows how many
tens of thousands of years of all of us
have spent working with sprocket afin in
this big transition to a world of
digital technologies and I think it's
time for us to really rethink what we're
going to do next and where this is all
going to go and what the options are and
we're in this very interesting
transitional period where one of the
statistics I've recently heard is that
attendance at theaters is at a 16 year
all-time low is that correct can
something like that this is not a good
sign and we're in an era now where
people are looking at our movies on
their computers and their television
sets and their their tablets and their
smartphones and our movies are being
shrunk and down but they are incredibly
inexpensive convenient easy to use easy
to access you can watch your movies
anywhere you want anytime you want and
this is having a profound effect on our
industry and one of the big things that
I think it's time for us all to do is
get back to how do people go out to the
movies and why do they go out to the
movies and how can we produce a
motion-picture experience that's so
spectacular on giant movie screens at
high brightness high frame rates if
that's necessary hi
bit depth better color saturation laser
projectors giant high gain screens and
all the things that we need to bring
together with the movies that we're
making now because we're making
spectacular movies now and there there's
something to be tremendously proud of
and it's all technology enabled we're in
this era now that's special effects
visual effects that I've been associated
with are becoming the core of our
business and we're creating characters
makeup wardrobe sets props locations
it's all being done digitally it's quite
an amazing new thing so I think we can
make movies that are unavailable any
other way so that people would choose I
want to go out to a movie tonight
because it's so cool and it's so big and
it's so grand and it's so spectacular
and there's so much showmanship that I
want to go out to a movie no at any
price
so finally I think we can bring movies
to new heights I want to thank my dad
Don Trumbull thank you very much